what's up you scruffy-looking nerf
herders I'm Walter Bernays yak and this
is top five here we countdown the best
and worst performances of our most
beloved actors today we chose Weiss and
take a look at the best of Harrison Ford
this top-5 is the result of a Twitter
poll I put up asking who should be the
last actor covered on top 5 for 2016
more polls will be going up on there
soon so if you want your voice heard
about who or what I'm going to cover
next make sure you follow me on twitter
at awesome underscore Walter Harrison
Ford is one of the biggest movie stars
ever since being thrust into the
spotlight 1977 Star Wars he's never
really dropped too far out of moviegoers
radar his filmography is one of the most
prolific in cinematic history including
some of the highest-grossing movies ever
made this 74 year old legend is still
going strong and I am honored to
countdown is top 5 best performances
number 5 Branch Rickey in 42 I know I
know this is not one of Ford's most
iconic roles but I believe his
performance in this Jackie Robinson
biopic earned its spot on this list many
people know who Jackie Robinson is he's
acknowledged as the first black player
to break the mo B's color barrier in
1947 however many people don't know the
story of how he was brought into the
majors and what he exactly faced once he
arrived 42 explores the narrative behind
the number Robinson was brought in to
the Brooklyn Dodger organization by
legendary general manager Branch Rickey
Robinson Rickey and the Dodgers all
faced heavy public scrutiny from a lot
of the nation at first as the season
went on Jackie slowly but surely let his
talent show his critics why he belongs
in the major leagues this only came out
a few years ago and proved Ford is still
at the top of his game he's almost
unrecognizable from the get-go and
actually ended up looking a lot like the
real Branch Rickey we don't see Ford in
roles like this very often so when he
excels at it this much it should be
taken notice of and commended you would
have play it as I have a guts to fight
back No
no I want to play her who's got the guts
not to fight back he's fantastic in 42
while disappearing into this baseball
legend his scenes with Chadwick Boseman
Jackie Robinson are always a highlight
and feels special but a time came when I
could no longer do that you
you let me love baseball again upon my
rewatching of this biopic I was still
initially really impressed by Harrison's
transformation however a big reason why
this didn't rank higher was that 42 over
exposed him just a little too much if he
had just been scaled back a touch I
think both the film and Harrison's
performance would have benefited greatly
an unconventional pick but it shows off
just how wide Ford's range is even this
deep into his career someday you're
gonna meet God and when he inquires is
why you didn't take the field against
Robinson in Philadelphia and you answer
that it's because he was a Negro it may
not be a sufficient reply number 4 dr.
Richard Kimble in the fugitive I love
this movie Ford as dr. Kimble brings us
thrills at last the entirety of the film
based in the 1960s TV series the
fugitive follows dr. Richard Kimble as
he's falsely convicted of murdering his
wife when the bus carrying him and a few
others to prison crashes and gets
destroyed by a train he manages to
escape custody and carefully starts
pursuing the real killer a one-armed man
he fought with the night his wife was
killed clothes on his trail is a team
led by US Marshal Samuel Gerard who is
as sharp as they come dr. Kimble's
thrilling chase of his wife's killer
while on the run from the cops himself
makes for an exhilarating run I should
mention this movie got his spin-off in
1998 surrounding the time Lee Jones
character called u.s. marshals but I
don't care since Ford is constantly on
the run here and just barely eluding
capture throughout the film his
character has to remain frantic but play
a cool one in front of other people
Harrison handled this balance
fantastically
[Music]
the film is filled with amazing moments
the stunt work and action scenes provide
the perfect backdrop for Harrison's
memorable performance
[Music]
mr. stop even while in the middle of the
precarious position he's in dr. Kimble's
instincts to help other people still
shine through and this adds even more to
his likability oh they sent this one of
confessors
[Music]
Oh get this one in the room for staff
Nigel
the fugitive is packed with great stuff
and is just as rewatchable as ever
thanks in large part to Ford's turn as
dr. Kimble number three ally Fox in the
Mosquito Coast I never saw the Mosquito
Coast before watching him for this list
and man have I missed that based on the
novel by Paul through the Mosquito Coast
is a tale about alley Fox and his
family's venture to live in the exotic
jungles of Panama alley is an inventor
who is fed up with the American Way of
life and decides to take his family to a
place where he believes they can live
without the pitfalls of American culture
Ali's family are reluctant the whole way
but followed their father through thick
and thin slowly they build up a
community with a group of locals but the
peril of the area starts to rear its
ugly head as Ally little by little
starts to lose his grip on his sanity
and his family's trust the premise makes
it seem like this movie could easily be
a bore but it's not Ford truly gives one
of his best performances with a little
help from Helen Mirren and a young River
Phoenix this feels like a pretty decent
departure from the roles Harrison is
best known for Ally Fox is a very proud
and eccentric man who thinks he knows it
all
how he deals with the problems that
arise for him and his family peel back a
few more layers to the character and
reveal some nice little flaws that make
him that much more human the Lord hasn't
any idea this place exists if he did he
would have done something for these
people a long time ago but he didn't
ideally this River doesn't belong to you
brother nor to you but this place
belongs to me and I didn't give you a
permission to come ashore his
interactions with his wife and children
especially Phoenix's character are
definitely the soul of the film Allie is
well respected by but still a huge
mystery to his eldest son Charlie trying
to find out what motivates him is a
great character arc for Phoenix and his
scenes with Ford feel very authentic
[Music]
don't pity those men charlie
buddy this insect not his blood at my
blood
as the film picks up we see things begin
to fall apart for the Fox family and
Allie's change in demeanor bring about
more great scenes
mr. Hattie well Jerry's right let's go
[Music]
Raiders
I think it's pretty safe to say that the
Mosquito Coast is a pretty hidden gem
nowadays seek it out for one of
Harrisons best rollers number two Han
Solo in the Empire Strikes Back so I
chose this Han Solo performance over a
new hope because I think in this one he
settled into the role a little bit more
and had more interesting character
interactions if you don't know the plot
to the Empire Strikes Back you should
probably go watch the Star Wars movies
in short the Rebel Alliance continues
its battle against the Galactic Empire
with dark turns taking hold of our
heroes especially Han Solo besides the
usual great Star Wars action the
original trilogy is known for at the
dramatic moments in this one really
carried the story as we get Han Solo at
his best his developing romance with
Leia is a main plot point and how that
progresses is still compelling to watch
let's go
darkness candle in your life I happen to
like nice man
nice man
I love you
I know when he does interact with Luke
in this one we see the expansion of that
friendship as well a deep respect has
grown between the characters and they've
been through so much together at this
point that they almost feel like family
the addition of Lando to the cast also
tacked on more depth to Hans backstory
this relationship expanded him as a
person while we catch a small glimpse
into his life before the rebellion the
trademark Han Solo wit is still present
here as well for some of the funnier
moments in the series I can arrange that
I don't know where you get your
delusions laser brain laugh it up
fuzzball many consider this to be the
best film in the Star Wars series and I
agree with that board created an icon in
a new hope but I think he fleshed Han
out and made him even more interesting
and Empire Harrison Ford isn't just a
huge movie star he's a great actor with
a ton of great performances so before we
get to number one here are some
honorable mentions
[Music]
and the number one best Harrison Ford
performance is Norman Spencer and what
lies beneath sight Indiana Jones in
Indiana Jones and the Last Crusade I
chose the Last Crusade for Ford's best
Indiana Jones performance for one main
reason his interactions with Sean
Connery in this third cinematic
adventure Indiana Jones is in search of
the Holy Grail in addition to fighting
Nazis and reteaming with his friends
Marcus Brody and Salah Indies father
Henry Jones senior joins the gang for
this exciting and final
I said final
I sent final installment in the revered
series this is Indiana Jones I think
it's pretty self-explanatory why I think
it's his best performance talk about
iconic we all love han Solo but Indiana
Jones showcases more of why Harrison
Ford is as popular as he is and the Last
Crusade we have a brand new adventure
but deal with issues of Indies past that
make him an even more well-rounded
character what you taught me was that I
was less important to you than people
who've been dead for 500 years in
another country and I learned it so well
that we've hardly spoken for 20 years
you left just when you were becoming
interesting Sean Connery as Indies
father is just so much fun to see his
chemistry with Ford jumps off the screen
and it's very easy to accept them as
father and son right away Uncle John yes
look can we discuss this later or
Sheetal mailed it to the Marx Brothers
will you take it easy jr. I told you
don't call me junior they have some
hilarious scenes together that still get
a solid laugh out of me how did you know
she was a Nazi hmm how did you know she
was a Nazi she talked from sleep
to balance that the drama between the
Jones boys holds a lot of weight Indy
feels like his father was never there
for him and Henry just doesn't seem to
understand that a few things are for
sure by the end of the film though they
both earn a newfound respect for each
other and genuinely care about each
other almost reach it dead
Indiana Indiana let it go
Ford was also great in Raiders and
Temple of Doom and I'm not trying to
diminish those performances but I think
his peak as Indy and in general was here
in the Last Crusade I want to hear what
you guys think what is your favorite
Harrison Ford movie and or performance
leave a comment and let me know and make
sure to check out awesome comics that
went up on YouTube yesterday because
we're talking about is row one better
than force awakens force force awakens
better than rogue one follow me on
twitter at awesome underscore Walter to
take part in more polls about who or
what I may cover in the future come back
next week for the final top five of 2016
[Music]
[Applause]
you